well Facebook's disastrous week is
continuing to get even worse thanks to
yet another scandal in 2012 it turns out
the company handed over user data to
Barack Obama's presidential campaign and
in doing so may have violated the law
Fox News 24-7 headlines anchor Brett
Larson has more on that Brett what do
you know hey Tucker yeah not a good week
to be Facebook basically what we're
finding out today is there's reports
that in 2012 they may have just given
user data to the Barack Obama campaign
there were reports in the Daily Mail
that the former person who ran the
Facebook campaign for Barack Obama the
social media for him that someone at
Facebook said we're giving this to you
because we agree with you of course
giving them that information for free
would be a violation of the federal
campaign finance laws because that would
be a violation of rather direct or
indirect giving of they're basically
giving a campaign donation in that
situation and you can't do that in
federal elections so both for the
President and for Congress then we're
also learning today that Hillary
Clinton's name coming up once again now
connected to all the problems with
Facebook that the app she was using
during the 2016 campaign and they were
encouraging people to connect with their
friends but they may have been going
through your contacts list and doing
that illegally and taking the data of
their users to encourage people to vote
for Hillary Clinton to try and find
people that they could persuade to be
voters not very good news for Facebook
all around and this is all in light of
the problems that they're having with
the Cambridge analytic a story that
we've been following for the past couple
of weeks with the 50 million users and
the data that was taken from them and
then this very I think damning piece of
information BuzzFeed's reporting on this
a former Facebook executive saying
something about what their site does and
how they connect people and he in part
says about Facebook anything that allows
us to connect more people more often is
de facto good despite the fact that they
had concerns that doing this could even
allow someone to coordinate a terrorist
attack or even expose someone to
bullying so Tucker it is a bad week to
be Facebook
yeah and it should be and I'm glad that
other people are paying attention to
this now not just us Brett thank you for
that thanks [ __ ]